selon vous il ya combien de langues
autochtones au canada ait à plusieurs je
n'ai pas augmenté
j'ai gagné beaucoup je crois qu'il y a
trois ou quatre longs j'imaginais 2 3
augie ray kahno une bonne quinzaine j'ai
pas plus je peux pas vous répondre
comme trois hauts cadres regret je
dirais peut-être une 10ème plus que ça
je dirais je sais pas une dizaine
peut-être nous centaines mais donnera
plusieurs j'ai l'impression 50 à 70
starwizz 60 langues autochtones au
québec peut-être cinq pour 3,95 à lomé
est 11e au québec est ce que vous savez
des noms de villes qui sont d'origine
autochtone déjà connu quelques-unes par
exemple maniwaki certainement mal à sa
mine pâle dit despatie kahnawake côté we
can oui ok c'est sa chute
il y avait aussi près de châteauguay les
villes
oui coup droit qui coûtait bout quoique
[Musique]
dit comme ça c'est ce sera les deux cas
je pourrais dire
peut-être ottawa je dirais chicoutimi
voilà bon moi j'en connais - cana moi
qui au cas je connais pas tant
quelques-unes sur la montérégie parce
que je demande kahnawake
il ya au corps canet s'attaquer
voilà c'est mon répertoire que si
justement quelqu'un et montréal et on se
demande quelles sont les communautés qui
sont proches ce n'est pas cannes s est
acquis segan awa guèye de draguer et
ghana wagué le cos edinger connaissait
des démos en langue autochtone importe
qu'elles n'ont aucun aucun nom oui et
pas un merci on dit a teenage komutel
tunis comité oui moi je m'appelle daniel
paul giniel de masse th scène
communautés innues au lac-saint-jean
donc chez nous vaut un bon jour on dit
cui cui cui et bonjour merci on dit qui
niche que 8ème cinechronicle ces niches
coup mitel comme items qui nichent
comité et peut dire merci à gignac
comité remercie en virginie retour mi
temps